[Music]
republican congresswoman marjorie
taylor-green is back in the news
remember her she's the lady who made
headlines when she yelled at
representative alexandria ocasio-cortez
through the mail slot on her office door
alexandria ocasio-cortez i'm an american
citizen i pay your salary through the
taxes that you collect from me through
the irs if you want to be a big girl you
need to get rid of your diaper and come
out and be able to talk to the american
citizens instead of having to use a flap
a little flap
well last week there was a hearing to
determine whether she should be
disqualified from seeking reelection
because of her public statements about
the january sixth
insurrection during the trial she was
questioned about calling speaker pelosi
a traitor here's a clip
in fact you think that speaker pelosi is
a traitor to the country right
uh you're i'm not answering that
question it's speculation you've said
that haven't you miss green that she's a
trader to the country no i haven't said
that okay
put up planets exhibit five please
oh no wait
hold on now
that's some big oh they got receipts
energy
looks like marjorie taylor green got
herself in some serious trouble amber
amber roofing oh no what is it marjorie
taylor green is at the door again that's
right i'm back and i'm suing you for
defamation
why
because you're making me look bad by
accusing me of saying things i actually
said
and then showing videos of me actually
saying them
marjorie if you said those things aren't
you just defaming yourself oh that's
some classic leftist trickery
you're like one of those mean jedis
doing mind tricks on those poor
stormtroopers
the storm troopers were the bad guys oh
you hear that america amber hates the
troops
get the hell out of here you can't get
rid of me that easy i brought back up
hello
hello
hello
hello
no
you brought representative madison
cawthorne and texas senator ted cruz
i sure did we're like the three amigos
but if they were white the three amigos
were white
what is wrong with you
let me in there
listen i will not let you cancel the
three amigos
madison cawthorn calm down sir oh what
are you gonna say next that i accused
republicans of having orgies
that's exactly what you did
stop twisting my words i do not love
orgies with old guys i didn't say you
did
no well good because that barely sounds
hot to me right now
you are gross
what's gross is how you and the woke mob
are trying to twist my words to make it
sound like i love orgies when i've
barely even been to enough orgies to
form an opinion
uh
just go to the green room
what's the green room oh is that where
the sex party is there is no sex party
oh well sure not till i get there yeah
stop attacking him oh shut up ted cruz
oh you'd love for me to shut up so you
can make it look like i want to see
mickey and pluto get it on
you said that in real life on the radio
and now the liberal media wants to make
it seem like all i do is think about
mickey and pluto doing it doggy style
please say less
oh sweaty and oily stop
and pluto has like really sick abs wait
okay let me get this straight the three
of you are mad at me and the rest of the
media for making you look bad that's
correct when all i did was repeat things
that you actually said in real life in
public also correct y'all need to leave
right now
good luck trying to get rid of us it's
our constitutional right to yell at you
through a mail slot
have you read the constitution uh
it's on my to-do list oh goodness look
you are a
[ __ ] i am amora
you want to leave and take your goofy
ass friends with you i want to leave and
take my goofy-ass friends with me
oh goofy's ass
i should have tried that sooner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you